this is from the guardian in and out
burger the popular fast food chain has
told employees in five states that
they'll no longer be allowed to wear
medical masks at work and could lose
their jobs if they refuse to comply
unless they have a note from their
doctor according to a company memo
leaked on Twitter the guidance is being
introduced to emphasis emphasize the
importance of customer service and the
ability to show our Associates smiles
and other facial features while
considering the health and well-being of
all individuals
it's set to go into effect on the 14th
of August for workers in Texas Nevada
Colorado Arizona and Utah unless they
have a specific medical condition or
health concern that requires them to
wear a mask along with a valid medical
note
employees who refuse to comply
will be disciplined up to including
termination of employment the policy
does not apply in California Oregon
where employers are prohibited from
Banning employee employees from masking
so in and out will potentially
and I sort of doubt they would actually
do this although I wish I hope they do
but in and out potential is going to
start firing their employees who still
wear masks which I think is great it's
exactly what you should do
and obviously all companies especially
in the service industry should adopt the
same policy
ban their employees from wearing masks
um it is among other things terrible
customer service to be covering your
face
when uh interacting with with your
customers
it's just it's it's uh it's ridiculous
and you look ridiculous
and uh so finally we're seeing a little
bit of Sanity on this let me ask you
something what if there was someone uh
out there who kept a log of every single
thing you did every minute of the day I
think that'd be pretty creepy wouldn't
it well what if I told you that's
exactly what happens every time you go
online your internet provider is allowed
to store logs of every website you've
ever visited you can legally and they
can legally sell this data to anybody
that's why I always use expressvpn
expressvpn reroutes your internet
internet connection through us their
secure servers so your internet provider
can't see or log what you do online now
many of you might be wondering well if
I'm routing all my data through a VPN
then does that just mean that the VPN
can see what I'm doing and log my data
instead many vpns claim to have a no
logs policy but have been caught logging
customer activity anyway expressvpn
servers run through Ram this uh makes it
impossible for their service to store
any data including logs of of any
expressvpn customers so you know you're
safe don't wait use my Link at
expressvpn.com Matt walshow to get three
extra months free that's exp
issvpn.com Matt walshow my only problem
is always with this sort of thing when
we see the Sanity on face masking coming
along three years after the fact is that
um you know as always these these these
concerns were laughed at
only a couple of years ago
you know now in and out is saying no
it's it's yeah you might be paranoid
about whatever virus you think you're
going to get you think that the mask is
doing something you might be paranoid
about that but the customers need to see
your face they need to see your smiling
face that's an important thing in
customer service like that is a priority
and so now we're hearing this but many
of us made this point all along
and of course we were laughed at for
that
that and this was this was my primary
argument with masking even apart from is
it effective is it not and all the rest
of it that's an important facet
but for me the most the the number one
point
was just like the
just the the the psychological effect of
walking around and not seeing anyone's
face we should we are human beings we
should be able to see each other's faces
out in public and that matters
it really does
and at the time if you said that you
were laughed out of the room
not about you getting banned on social
media ever saying
three years later
and here we are
if you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed